I was gonna say that like obviously if
you're dating in your like your pool and
you've got an amazing job then surely
you you want a partner that like matches
you in so much like so your job not
necessarily I don't know I'm not a man
so maybe not maybe not all men but I
think I think
the demographic men who want their women
to actually be successful successful
yeah
care about women's job what she does but
I want it to not be not involve her
being naked or anything like that and I
want it to be something that she enjoys
um and
it's about it really like I I you know
that's it but there's still a level and
I wanted to have one it would be nice if
she has one